[Music]
some of the intrinsic facilities that
are part of the toolkit are on this
slide here there's some some facilities
here for collecting input this is
essentially a slight enhancement of the
facilities did you find currently in X
live X next event X pending and stuff
like that the the enhancements are to
allow for allow applications or widgets
to to choose to connect to non X devices
and have have input from them be final
in as events and also to provide for a
mechanism for timeouts but otherwise
there's sort of a one-to-one
correspondence between the DX lab X next
event and and the X T next event which
which is which is the corresponding
toolkit version then there's an event
dispatcher which is which which every
Ridgid will typically on coming into
existence register the register itself
with the event dispatcher as you as I
mentioned earlier the X window is the
name of the widget so the widget will
call the call the event dispatcher
dispatcher say this is my X Window name
and here's the routine to call me when
an event comes along there also this is
this module also provides functionality
so that the application can can can can
dispatch events by saying here's an
event that I read off the input queue
take care of it
we just talked about geometry management
there are facilities to register
geometry management procedures with
widgets there's a selection management
capability this is pretty much a
straight interface to some of the
parameters that the version 11
a protocol provides for selection and
and and to allow the widget riders to
have to be able to conveniently access
that functionality that's a version 11
once again we chose to use Adams just
like the people in in the in the service
in the protocol and server
implementation groups the reason we have
a separate atom management that is
different from from this from the server
is performance we didn't want to have to
go to the server every time so this is
sort of a client-side atom management
facility there's a generalized
association table which which is used
directly by widgets and it's used by
some of the other facilities to
associate various data structures with
different in smidgeon instances a
resource manager is is we have a
prototype of a resource manager
currently which which basically provides
a database that that that stores things
like X resources plus it's a fairly
open-ended variety of things that you
can add to the day that you can act you
can store in the database and retrieve
the visit riders then can the interface
is available to the widget riders allow
you to to to access information that has
been stored in the database and and also
have the have the underlying resource
management do type conversions for
example you may you may you may want to
to have it put out some text in your
widget and you may want to know what
font to use the resource manager you may
want to know know the font as as a
content for perhaps and and the resource
the database may have the fonts stored
as a string well there's there's some
conversion facilities built in and as
you add your own resource types there
are ways to add your own conversion
routines to do the conversion between
the various resources
there's there's a translation manager
which basically says a widget when it
receives an in an event from from the
outside may choose to say I'll translate
the these these translate here's a list
of events that I'm interested in but I
really want to want to perform actions
that are specific to my world and to
have a have an entity out there that
performs the translation for example a
widget implementing an eMac style editor
may may may want to see see a command
saying move to the beginning of a line
when control a is typed and then there's
some some facilities for common error
handling the communication with widgets
is primarily through aside from the
initial creation request is is primarily
through through messages we propose a
primitive XD send message and you give
the window corresponding to the massive
visit and you give what the type of the
message is and an argument lists the
types of the messages some of the common
types that we envision right now are the
following by the way these are atoms so
so this is an open-ended list as need
arises the these seem to be types that
are fairly common for most widgets and
the any widget is free to extend this
and add types that are more meaningful
for in terms of the argument list we
have a structure which basically has
name value pairs and they names are
atoms so for example a widget could say
move this scroll bar scroll bar thumb to
such and such an offset so there could
be an atom sayings a thumb move or
something and and and the offset would
then be perhaps in a floating point a
number which says where in the in the in
the along the length of the scroll bar
the thumb is to be moved to
so the the interaction with with widgets
in terms of passing parameters is done
primarily through lists like this the
creation routine itself when it provides
the resources that the widget needs
overriding those that may come from the
resource manager also provides them in
using structures of this form this is
just a list of some of the widgets that
we think we will be able to provide in
the time frame and and most of these are
common ones buttons
whereas flavors of radio buttons are
picking out of any any number out of em
buttons and textual sub windows and
where are we well we put out a proposal
that was about him about a month ago and
we asked when we put out the proposal
that feedback be with you in the very
near future it realized a lot of this
urgency is being driven by by this end
date and in order for this end for there
to be anything meaningful by this end
date things have to start firming up
earlier and earlier here otherwise it's
unrealistic to make this as it is
they're very iffy about this so the we
plan to take some of the feedback that
we've already received some and we'll
incorporate that produce an updated spec
and then we we are we currently have a
good bit of the ideas we have presented
implemented on version 10 servers based
on version 10 clients client libraries
we have in fact as of yesterday I think
everything in the intrinsic layer that
I've described has complete or pretty
close to where we have several several
widgets and in fact several applications
using widgets written just to debug our
ideas all of them down on top of X
version 10 since since this this we will
not have access to this version 11
server for a little while yet we produce
we plan to to complete it to produce a
subset implementation of what I offer
the things I said rough roughly around
the start of March and this would be an
implementation done in version 10 it
would be we'd be happy to to provide
this in source form along with whatever
documentation we have around that day
following then following that we will
then be working on the version version
11 release this this is going to be a
really hard day to make and
hopefully we'll make it this is when
version 11 goes out of the door I'm all
done
any questions
the question is how does this relate to
X menu is X menu being used as part of
this the answer is it's the emphasis
here is on being able to build things
like X menu one of the things that
somebody somebody could do and I'm not
saying we will do is actually layer X
menu on top of the primitives we have
here we will have a menu implementation
package that will that will go out with
this I'm not sure we'll have X menu
these are all all the widgets and and
intrinsic managers are part of the
address space of the client in that
sense you
and the question is is XD send message
within within the within the client
address space or does go the server it
is within the client grant outer space
yes
the number of things which is visible on
your screen that one application
if you put 3,000 top oval windows all
over your screen I guarantee you things
will go slow this has been done it works
but it's crazy but you know 150
scattered among different different
widgets so they're opposed and larger
frames back there
Hiller Packard is especially concerned
about that maybe you can the question
question was what are you are you
concerned what kind of applications are
you considering building with this
toolkit any real-time applications
[Laughter]
the answer is I can't I can't speak for
any specific product plans but
hewlett-packard makes lots of
instruments
question is some of the widgets are
described as being circular elliptical
and ex windows being rectangular how do
you resolve this conflict
I can't recollect which widgets for
circular elliptical but if but if they
were it's just it's just a it's just for
graphical niceties I mean it's it's yeah
there's a bounding rectangle around
it yes
[Laughter]
last question
well well hopefully the the text widget
that we provide will be going in that
direction it may not have all the
functionality that you need to do the
question was do you have the
functionality in there to do busy week
type of applications the answers that
all the hooks are in there if you the
basic intrinsics are there for you to do
your job go to it and give us one here
[Applause]
the guy is super responsible for really
making this conference work okay
characteristically late but we would
like to encourage people to stay around
for a while for questions and answers
and we're open to things here I mean you
can talk you can ask questions about any
of these speakers you've heard today
other things I want to encourage a lot
of people have been asking me is anybody
doing mumble and I say okay great thing
to ask tough here is they stand up and
shop is anybody doing mumble you know
let's meet over there if you're doing
mumble after Q&A okay so those things
are encouraged as well
tattoo okay
the mic has been put away so people are
just going to have to challenge
questions okay there are a couple of
different answers to that one
possibility that has been kicked around
and I don't know whether it's actually
being pursued yet is to actually build a
version 10 server that speaks version 11
out the back end okay and layer the
servers on top of each other this will
be a bootstrap this is not a long-term
solution okay this is to say I've got
version 11 clients that I'm really
interested in running and I haven't
converted some of these crusty version
10 applications yet okay but I still
want to use them okay this allows this
will give you a mechanism to do that
okay another strategy is worrying about
converting tools how do I convert from
version 10 the version 11 okay there are
some ideas around there there are no
warm bodies who any companies have
identified to work on that problem
there's only so much that people inside
Athena can do okay if there are vendors
out there who would like to stand up and
be counted
to contribute something that would be a
very useful thing to try
maybe the two of you ought to get
together if you're both working on it
say right alpha test is coming soon okay
another question that's not a question a
couple of things have been named here
today protocol documentation was
described earlier you can get that off
of ZAP you were not the presentation I
mean I can put this information on the
board again is there anybody else who
didn't get the information you're gonna
anonymous FTP it off of zap dot MIT that
news if you don't know the Internet
address go look it up
the toolkit proposal is on the v10 are
for tape it's also available via an
honest FTP to zap X live documentation
for version 11
[Music]
you don't want to make it ft cable off
of that so is be 10 hour for well you
could put you could put a line printer
output there whatever your
really is there any is there I assume
that there's that vendors are some of
the vendors that are doing servers are
gonna have better documentation
if vendors contributed you have to
realize that that you know as far as MIT
is concerned project Athena does not
have enormous staff to contribute to
this
she should talk to Ralph
are you selling it independently
[Applause]
[Music]
have we been able to choose between them
one was really demonstrable II
considerably better than the other when
you know fallback
we had customers who have to migrate
quite the 40 tap on the stable and
did a lot of talk about policy and on
library number better food exactly the
opposite way totally strange user
interface right now programmers
by the vendors or by us you see I mean
to me it's not if it's not something
that I can answer the vendors would have
the answer for themselves I mean there
is a war to be fought inside you'd have
to ask that or Braille
okay as far as Athena is concerned you
know they're sort of in this situation
by default at the moment but get it back
from centers rather than giving it yes
both inna would like to get out of the
business we're a long way from one that
everybody buys into I'm sure you're
gonna see examples of this there you
know at CMU the Ender project okay is
going to be building a tiling window
manager okay and that's going to be
what's on campus basically okay I'm sure
they're gonna have a user you know
application level you know the user
interface to go with that that all their
applications are riveted they will be
you know redesign of their current
so you know within within giving
universities you're gonna see I'm sure
within vendors we're gonna see the same
kind of thing their application Suites
that they provide will be written to
some standard well weather vendors can
get together and agree on the answer is
that I can't answer off the top of my
head I mean given that it's going
through the ARPANET there are
restrictions on how you can use the
ARPANET okay it's nothing peculiar about
expert
in general people asking about new
people you know some anybody else
working on mumbles that's perfectly fine
okay and the usual policy is sort of if
someone asked about mumble then you can
sort of tell them yes there's the
factors product that you could go by
that does one mole okay but for the year
but it has to be in response to somebody
[Music]
okay how much money would you how many
people would pay a hundred dollars to
come to this
$200
this was a lot of work okay and a lot of
you work on the part of people who have
never done this before and would like to
give back in some fundamental research
that they've been avoiding
[Music]
is
because even though they verify that we
are going to send you information about
the videotape everybody okay it's an
expert
I think there are a lot of people either
either we should send it to everybody we
should announce it they're all the same
we will post the expert we will try and
post expert the names of all the
speakers and their addresses again we
have wanted them
those
[Music]
no that was a questioner statements of
repeated
my tea
there is a system at Berkeley
yeah yeah that's prank prank at Berkeley
is available and you can just start you
could just have TP to it and get
whatever you want it's kind of an open
open distribution fit bucket and stuff
kind of waters in there and
unfortunately sometimes it gets in there
and it's broken but sure anything
anything you're interested in fact
everybody ought to do this just get on
to prank at berkeley.edu and there's
directories there and there should be
some readme files they explain what's
there PR AMG recommendation for all the
files that are stored on zap would be
convenient if they also have been copied
into a similar directory structure on
praying to avoid many many megabytes ok
I'll mention that to the guys that are
running that big I don't know but that
machine is actually a belongs to to one
of the people I think it was actually
donated from Dec and I don't know if
he's got the disk space but if he's got
the business space I'm sure they'd be
glad to do that so someone who would
like to volunteer to become official
repository it's not me somebody's
already doing it at Berkeley for the
local environment
do you think it says the possibility
least set up a distribution somewhere in
Europe that we could get really all this
material and distributed on takes more
than any legal or export license I mean
I think I think the the stuff I'm crying
I sort of a lineage sort of what
students put there it's real random yeah
it's really a random assortment of stuff
about that substance why various random
things I tend to pick up with early
sport a was I didn't know where they
come from stop out of MIT we are some
believe we know where it all came from
and you know believe in hope that there
is no legal problems we'll distribute it
to anybody who wants them okay but there
was other stuff on Frank I wouldn't just
assume distribute it but in fact just
didn't have time to sort of track down
the state of it that sort of the the
difference practices random thing
there's a distribution state which is
believed to be consistent and have some
chance of building
I mean
[Applause]
is there any reconciliation between use
and X or ever beat any Adobe Systems
Incorporated today plans to develop a
version of postscript for displays which
will be suitable for use as a graphics
extension to windowing systems
PostScript the page description language
developed by Adobe is leading standard
for printing on high quality printers
and typesetters Adobe's new package will
give her members both the PostScript
language interface and a C language
interface of a complete range of
PostScript with powerful graphic and
font capabilities it will be a full
implementation of the language and will
be completely compatible with the
printer version applications will be
able to use a windowing system to
manipulate
windows and use postscript to create
their images within a window and a fully
device-independent manner
this will make it possible to present on
the screens of the same text and
graphics that can now be printed by
postscript laser printers and things
others
the x1 doesn't stuff at all with it that
my team supported by a large number of
core station vendors is one of the one
of the system's before which in a
postscript extension will be available
but though the expects to have a package
completed by the fourth quarter of this
year for licensing an imodium the basis
to workstation manufacturers PostScript
is a registered trademark of Adobe
Systems Incorporated and Robinson Adobe
Systems that's what they said questions
any more questions
you touch briefly on to the point that
Springs and the x11 protocol can be
encoded and 16-bit encoded characters
have you ever looked and saw mixed
representations like the International
teletext alphabet which uses the air
critical side which is very important
you respond to the question is about
mixed character representations 8 and
16-bit the Xbox 100 teletext stuff it's
on terms of how many Matt what the
encoding is a particularly live display
and I think a lot of presented in Japan
so for example European vendor would
choose to present a lot of European
fonts ok present the biting buttocks
they wish and as leaving a little Bay
there's not a lot of standardization
there I think we see that
and I think
okay there is the issue of what Bluff is
where that's an interesting problem yes
now there's a in aspect as a recommended
Athenian anticipable this is recommended
encoding for Japanese language systems
of data 16-bit space but there's a
problem with the European language
because there aren't very many
agreed-upon standards
constrain and standardize the extensions
again the intent is that whoever owns
the protocol can own what it means to
bless an extension as you know now part
of the core okay and presumably that
same organization can can be the place
where people trying to propose
extensions and can get their proposals
circulated for review show up in the
room in each room hopefully there will
be a chair person who will try and keep
the discussion coherent believes they're
named in the handout except the window
manager is going to be Markman ass
anymore that was what was on the slide
that was for the first round
and really over
okay that's it
[Applause]
[Music]